Rusia introduce fuertes medidas en las
cuatro regiones recientemente
anexionadas de Ucrania el presidente
ruso quien culpa a kiev de la situación
hizo los anuncios
Permítame recordarles que la ley Marcial
estaba en vigor en la República Popular
de Daniel la República Popular de
lugares en las regiones de gerson y
saporilla desde su entrada en el
territorio de Rusia y ahora por lo tanto
es necesario aplicar esta ley dentro del
marco legal ruso
por lo tanto he firmado un decreto sobre
la introducción de la ley Marcial en
estas cuatro zonas de la federación rusa
esta decisión hace parte de la última
escalada por parte del kremlin para
intentar minimizar las derrotas contra
Ucrania en el frente de batalla de hecho
en gerson la primera ciudad que cayó en
manos rusas el ejército histó a los
habitantes abandonar la zona ante un
supuesto ataque ucraniano
en esta circunstancia es nuestra
prioridad es preservar la vida y la
salud de los civiles por lo tanto en
primer lugar ejército ruso garantizará
la salida segura de la población que ya
ha sido anunciada en el marco del
programa de reasentamiento que está
preparando el gobierno en Rusia
pretenden evacuar entre 50.000 y 60.000
personas en los próximos seis días
Tenemos aquí dos filas de personas que
solicitaron a través del centro de
llamadas a la derecha está la fila de
los que se dirigen a olesky y a la
izquierda la fila de los que se dirigen
ahora prestando mientras Ucrania intenta
recuperar la planta de energía nuclear
de Sa polilla controlada por Rusia en la
mañana del miércoles un contingente
llegó por lancha hasta el lugar pero El
Avance fue repelido por el ejército ruso